rachel green is one of the most beloved
characters on friends but is she a good
friend after a long casting period a
then relatively unknown jennifer aniston
landed the role the last friends
character to be cast during friends the
reunion the series producers also
admitted that in the wrong hands rachel
would have been very unlikable and it
took so long to find the perfect person
to portray her you know when i did it at
first i was scared but then look at me
now i am the only daughter that dad is
proud of though aniston did make rachel
a character millions of fans across the
world love there's a lot about her that
isn't so great for one rachel is a
pretty horrible roommate she barely
cooks doesn't help clean up and refuses
to move out of the apartment even when
monica wants to leave and live with her
boyfriend chandler rachel was a bully in
high school and pretty self-centered as
an adult and who could forget the time
she lost ross's pet monkey marcel
because she didn't want to miss her soap
opera that's not to mention rachel's
messy love life early on rachel leaves
her fiance barry at the altar and she
later has an affair with him while he's
married to mindy rachel's longtime best
friend who served as the maid of honor
in her cancelled wedding to berry later
in the series rachel flies to england
and inadvertently breaks up ross's
wedding to emily and in a totally cringy
storyline she also hooks up with ross's
best friend joey however these moments
pale in comparison to something terrible
rachel does to monica in a friend scene
that simply goes too far over the course
of the series run rachel does some
things to monica that aren't very best
friendly for example in season 2 when
the pair visit the set of the movie
outbreak 2 the virus takes manhattan
they spot actor jean-claude van damme
monica reveals to rachel that she has a
huge crush on the actor but is too
nervous to talk to him rachel approaches
him acting as if she'll put in a good
word for monica and ends up securing a
date with the movie star herself in a
flashback scene to the 1980s from a
later episode rachel kisses chandler
while knowing monica was crushing on him
but the worst was yet to come in the
season 7 episode the one with monica's
thunder rachel starts feeling lonely
because monica has found her person in
chandler and she still hasn't on the
night of a planned outing to celebrate
the newly engaged couple's news rachel
goes to ross and starts kissing him
planning a bonus one night stand night
with him monica opens her apartment door
to see her brother kissing rachel in the
hall she accuses the exes of stealing
all of the attention by reuniting on
what was supposed to be her big night
for monica this was the rachel move that
really went too far while that scene has
gone down in history as one of rachel's
worst moments she later one-ups monica
at her own wedding just before monica
and chandler's wedding phoebe discovers
a discarded positive pregnancy test in
the trashcan of monica and chandler's
bathroom she believes that it's monica's
but when monica clears the air and says
she isn't expecting phoebe makes a snap
decision and pretends she is to cover
for rachel later on rachel takes a
pregnancy test during the wedding
reception when monica is supposed to be
celebrating many friends fans agree that
rachel could have gone about this
differently and not overstepped on
monica and chandler's special day as
this was coming near the end of the
series run for friends it makes sense
sitcoms generally have to keep upping
the ante as they move forward leading to
this major shift for the final few
seasons though monica isn't upset with
rachel about what happens on her wedding
day a detail that baffles fans to this
day the icing on the spotlight stealing
cake is the fact that when rachel gives
birth to her daughter she names her emma
the name monica wanted to name her
daughter one day classic rachel green
move
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv series are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]